the thing is um the thing is you know
doubts they are they are there they are
obviously there but the thing that was
suppressing you know you know everything
is questioning is you know this this
Faith or this Blind Faith that you said
that is the that is basically the
obstacle so when that is you know out of
the way everything's just comes you
know like everything it's like a flood
you know
yes
God
[Music]
how's it
going so I just wanted to say one thing
are are you a
Muslim yes a Muslim welcome to the
panel so I see your life sometimes you
talk about Muhammad did this you bring
up the
hadiths but the problem here is that
you're basing everything on Western
ideologies okay you know you're saying
this Muhammad he did this to his wife he
struck his wife he did this but this are
the ideologies from the kufar you
know do you think do you think that
these Western ideologies that I'm using
are good ideology like do you think it's
good to not hit your wife for a man not
to hit his wife you think that's a good
virtue so I believe what is good is
decided by Allah subhana tala is not
decided by especially not the KU they do
not decide what is good and what is bad
what is what
is Prophet Muhammad if our Prophet does
something Prophet Al wasallam if he does
it and there on it Scholars agree on it
then we as Muslims we have nothing to
say they have nothing to say okay that
okay I guess that answers the question
so basically
um this Western ideology that I have
that a man should never hit his wife
because she is a weaker vessel she's
he's stronger physically and he's meant
to protect her and provide for her and
love her like he loves his own self
you're saying that that is
a a ideology of a disbeliever and it's
not a good ideology just to be
clear no what I'm saying is that it's
not that the Quran is not saying you
know the husband can just hit his wife
There are rules you have to follow um
there are steps you know you know it's
saying that if in case of you know
Disobedience or something like that if
you fear if you fear Disobedience yes
fear yes yes so this she doesn't even
have to commit an act of Disobedience
it's if you fear it he's able to do what
he and another another problem is that
you know when you ask too much questions
you know why is Allah doing this
why is it like this you know as a Muslim
you can fall into you know doubts and
you can start question why Allah doing
something good and you know Allah knows
better than we do he created us so I
don't think so I think Muslims you don't
you don't question what Allah does
that's just simple well that's what you
just said is important what you just
said is very very important the second
that you begin to question
these commands or permissibility and
actions of
Allah
then that gives room for you to now
doubt Allah and Islam and you shouldn't
be doing that is what you're saying what
you said is extremely important which is
why I say that this is that's cult
mentality for you to not
question Allah and these commands and
these verses and Hadith and the actions
of Muhammad because
it'll cause you to start doubting here's
my thing I think that even you as a
Muslim that you are better than Muhammad
and Allah that you have better
values I can I think I can prove that to
you okay so I I will say that is
incorrect because Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam he was the
best man to walk on the earth he is the
best example we follow so me as a Muslim
um I commit many sins you know he is the
best to walked this
Earth M committ many s the
prophet Muhammad committed many sins
too did you know
that but at the end of the day he is the
best example the best man to walk the
earth so I cannot as for him as a
messenger of Allah Allah has chosen him
I cannot compare myself to the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam that that's
just let me ask you let me ask you this
let me ask you this is a
um is a person who sins is a person who
sin who sins a better example than one
who does not
sin so this is this is exactly what my
point was earlier the point was now
you're asking many questions and the
problem is that we stray further from
Allah and what he has decided we start
to question what
some his um his decisions why so why
would Allah choose the prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam you know if
he wasn't uh going to be a good example
you know so in if we we can see this as
Prophet Allah subhana T he already knows
what prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he would do he already knows it
you know so you know we as Muslims
obviously we believe that Allah he knows
everything he's the who created us you
know yeah I didn't ask that so it's it's
okay to ask questions sister it's okay
to ask critical thinking questions okay
if you are going to question Allah's
decisions then it's you are on dangerous
G well see this man this is this is you
man I I am glad that you came up because
this is bringing a this is giving good
light on Muslim you know ideology you
know unreal Muslim ideology you're not
supposed to critically think you're not
supposed to um ask critical questions
and and deduce things and things in
Islam you're you're not supposed to do
that when I asked you this basic
question you're right of who do you
think is a better example one who sins
or one who does not sin you're even
saying that that's a dangerous question
because it can lead you to doubting
Allah that's deep
yes that's true let me let me let me
share with you something with the
so I know you may not believe because
you know you're a Muslim you may not
believe in the previous scriptures um
but in in the previous scriptures the
prophet Isaiah God reasoning with Israel
he tells Israel to come he says let us
reason together this is God talking
saying come let us reason together he
and invites the people of Israel to
reason with
him you know to critically think with
him because God is confident enough to
reason with his people to know that the
conclusion is that he is the best option
and that he knows what's best for them
and he can reason with them to come to
that conclusion
too but in Islam it's the opposite
you're not supposed to reason with Allah
you can't because then you start
doubting well I'm thinking how can you
reason with the one who created you the
one who already knows everything
everything he knows everything he knows
more than what you do and he he knows
more than what your brain is capable of
knowing you know just answer that how is
it possible how can you question
decisions that God's make he knows
everything everything that you don't
know more than you know well well it's
it's it's like this because God gave us
a
a mind for a reason and our mind
reflects him this this uh this this this
uh aspect of reason that we have and
questioning you know it it's it's
reflective of God he has given us this
mind to inquire to be creative to deduce
and think you know what I'm saying it's
a reflection of him
so that's why we're able he allows us to
think when it comes to him and you know
question in sincerity not question as in
we're putting God on you know on the hot
seat and we're the judges not in that
way you know we don't we don't question
God in that way but it's just far as you
know just questioning or having
questions about his commands or what
what he wants from us and his desires
and his purpose and these are this
that's okay he he invite the true God in
invites that only a false god would not
want you to question or Reason with him
only a false god who's afraid of you
doubting and using your brain to where
you're now coming outside of the
darkness and coming outside of that box
only a false god a false God will give
this ideology that you're not supposed
to think or question in that
way but that that is what faith is Faith
is believing something that is there's
no you know there's no evidence you know
from the KU there's no evidence in that
way but we have faith we believe even
though we haven't seen it with our own
eyes we we know that there's been a
prophet he has he has delivered his
message and we believe in that message
this is something this is Faith well
well that's we have we have two
different definitions of what faith is
what you just described Is Blind Faith
the Bible actually says that faith is
the subst
of things hoped for the evidence of
Things Not Seen that's the book of
Hebrews so how the Bible defines faith
is that faith has substance to it faith
has evidence to it even though you
haven't seen the particular thing yet
but there's
evidence right and and substance to why
you should trust so faith is trusting in
the evidence that you have in the result
that you have seen yet that's what faith
is Blind Faith is just believing blindly
you know with no evidence no substance
that's what you described as Blind Faith
the Bible doesn't say that's what faith
is the Bible says faith is based on
evidence but the thing is there's
there's many things you know in even in
Islam that we don't know we say Allah
God knows best the things we that are
not answered so we don't know if it's
true or we don't know you know the why
it is you know so we trust Allah we say
God knows best and we don't dive deeper
we don't start questioning that so we we
we base everything
on what the scholars have provided for
us um and Faith yeah so Bally yeah but
there's there's an issue here yes there
are instances right where God knows best
there's instances where we we can't lean
on our own understanding like we're
limited so we got to just give it up to
God God knows he his ways are not like
ours and stuff like that but that
doesn't eliminate the ability to
question things at all you have to be
able to reason with your faith you have
to be able to reason with your world
view you as a Muslim you have to have a
reason why you're you're saying the the
Quran is true why Islam is true you
can't just say allaham I just accept
Islam that's it I believe it's from God
boom boom boom that's it you have to
have a reason for your faith even even
the Bible says this too notice how what
what you're saying and like that's in
Islam in Christianity it's completely
different in Christianity it says to be
able to give a reason for your faith
when asked give a reason be able to
defend your faith
right you're supposed to be able to do
that in the truth only in a lie would it
not want you to critically think to give
an answer to reason only in a cult in a
lie does it profess such
ideologies if you can't simply reason
with me you know as just us human beings
on who what is a better example to
follow a sinner or a nons sinner if you
can't reason with me on something as
basic and simple as that that's a
problem the thing is that at the end of
the day we Muslims we believe what has
been presented you know to us the
prophet Muhammad sallah alaihi wasallam
his message in the Quran the Holy Quran
that he the Revelation he got that is
what we believe and the Quran is
indestructible the Quran there's nothing
that can be no no human can produce
anything like the Quran not even one
single verse that is what is in the that
what the Quran says no human can can do
I like that unique book it's a unique
book now now do you see what you're
doing now what you're doing is now
you're giving me Arguments for Islam so
this is what I would ask you sister if
then you were to find out that someone
was able to make a verse like it even a
single verse that would then prove the
false right because the Quran says
that's impossible so if someone was able
to do that then that would prove the
Quran false right yes if you're using
that logic yes it would it would true
beautiful but no one can't so that's the
other argument no one can't I got you so
this is what I want to show you sis I
want to show you that this actually
happened and I want you to show you that
this happened within Islam Umar are you
familiar with
Umar yes you're talking
that's right
Omar he actually came up with three
verses that were like the Quran in fact
they were so much like the Quran that
they actually became verses of the Quran
let me show you this sah
alkari
4483 it says Umar said I agreed with
Allah in three things or said my Lord
agreed with me in three things I said oh
Allah's
messenger would that you
took the station of Abraham as a place
of prayer all right and then that verse
was revealed I also said oh Allah's
messenger good and bad persons visit you
would that you ordered the mothers of
the Believers to cover themselves with
veils so the Divine verses of alh hijab
were revealed I came to know that the
prophet had blamed some of the his wives
So I entered upon them and said you
should either stop troubling the prophet
or else Allah will give his Apostle
better wives than you when I came to one
of his one of his wives she said to Umar
oh Umar does Allah's messenger have what
he could advise his wives with that you
try to advise them thereupon Allah
revealed
it may
be if he divorced you his Lord will give
him instead of you wives better than you
Muslims chapter 66 verse5 that's
literally what Umar
said so Omar was able to come up was
able to say three things that were so
good that they even became Quran
verses
so that means that the the challenge has
been met oops and the Quran is false
yeah I don't have an answer to this I
don't know that's fair enough maybe the
explains or
something you know I'll just I'm just
saying this sister and you don't have to
give an answer like right now or
anything like that I'm just saying that
um when we
begin to
critically think about the challenges
that the Quran sets up for us
right and we see and we go into this and
dive into it you were right that when we
begin to challenge the Quran or think
critically we're going to you're going
to see that it's not it's it's not true
it's
false by even by the quran's own
standards I mean I I see your I see your
logic you know um but I don't know yeah
but the thing is sometimes I see you
know a lot of lives like this and they
pull up hadiths and the hadiths you know
from the outside you know looking in
they might look very like
ridiculous um but you know as Muslims
it's like we cannot be like oh this is
this is false this is ridiculous you
even if you think that you can't you
can't say that you know so there was
there was an example um of in one Hadith
where the there was I think it was a
Hadith about Moses it was a stone
something was a stone who who stole his
clothes or something yeah and you know
at first thought that is very like
ridiculous like why are you beating up a
stone you know so but it's like as
Muslims you gotta like suppress those
thoughts it's like you can't think no no
no as a Muslim you do not did you guys
hear what she just said she said as a
Muslim you got to suppress those
thoughts no you let those thoughts rise
you think you know it's ridiculous so
don't don't suppress it challenge it let
if if Allah is true and Islam is true
then it should be able to withand the
scrutiny of your
doubts if Islam is true it should be
able to withstand your critical thinking
and reasoning
skills but it can't what you have to do
is suppress your thoughts suppress your
reasoning suppress your critical
thinking so that you can stay a
Muslim I say God forbid and I invite you
to a better way within Christ you do not
have to suppress the truth in
unrighteousness you don't have to
suppress it within Christ you can ask
these questions you can bring your
reasoning to Christ lay it before him
and he answers
you how do you know that you you know
that you are invited to question and
challenge in the in Christianity how do
you know that that's literally the
Commandment greatest commandment love
the Lord your God with all your heart
mind and
soul so he invites us to be emotionally
connect connected with him heart have
our heart love him with all our heart to
be spiritually connected with him love
him with all our soul and to
intellectually be in love with him love
him with all our
mind that's what our God invites us
to okay so then my question would be why
is you know why is a Christ the
truth very good question why is Christ
the truth this is what Jesus says in
John chap CH 14 he says I am the way the
truth and the
life no one comes to the father except
through me let me let me show you what
convinced me I'm gonna read you
something and you tell me who this is
about okay I promise you you're going to
get it it says surely he has borne our
griefs and carried our
sorrows yet we esteemed him stricken
smitten by God and
Afflicted but he was pierced for our
transgressions he was crushed for our
iniquities upon him was the punishment
that brought us peace and with his
wounds we are healed all we like sheep
have gone astray we have turned everyone
to his own way and the lord has laid on
him the sins of us
all sister n who does that sound like to
you Jesus I think Jesus yes yep sounds
exactly like Jesus now here's what's
interesting about this I'm not reading
the gospel I'm not reading anything in
the New Testament I'm reading the book
of Isaiah this is the book Isaiah book
of Isaiah prophet Isaiah chapter
53 and in chapter 53 of Isaiah this is
700 years before Jesus is born but in
you know Islam we we think that um that
was not Jesus God already they took him
up to the you know he already it was
someone else that died on the on the
cross not Jesus GNA read you another
passage you tell me what it sounds
like this is Psalm 22 sister it says I
am poured out like water and all my
bones are out of joint my heart is like
Wax it is melted within my breast my
strength is dried up like a post herd
and my tongue tongue sticks to my jaws
you lay me in the dust of death for dogs
Encompass me a company of evildoers
encircles me they have pierced my hands
and my feet who does that sound like
sister Jesus yep so we have Isaiah
prophet Isaiah speaking of Jesus talking
about him being pierced him dying for
our sins and things of this nature
and you also have Prophet David daud in
the zabor in the psalms prophesying
about the Messiah saying that he will be
pierced having his hands and his feet
pierced being surrounded by his enemies
mocked and
ridiculed that's two let me show you
another one let's go to the Torah
Moses to the Book of Genesis the very
first book of the Bible then God said to
the serpent I will put
enity between you and the woman between
your seed and her seed he shall bruise
your head while you shall bruise his
heel let me ask you who is The Offspring
of the
woman Jesus exactly let me show you one
more
Zechariah Chapter
12 verse 10 so this is God speaking he
says this
and I will pour out on the House of
David and the inhabitants of Jerusalem a
spirit of Grace and pleas for mercy so
that when they look on me on him whom
they have
pierced they shall mourn for him as One
Mourns for an only child and weep
bitterly over him as one weeps over a
firstborn now we've been seeing a theme
here who according to all all the
scriptures that we've been seeing is the
one that's pierced sister who is
that yes it sounds like it sounds like
Jesus it's Jesus now let me ask you
this when you have all of the
scriptures all of the scriptures all
agreeing with the same thing hold on let
me get you Jesus now let me just finish
it off with Jesus in Luke CH 24: 44- 46
this what he says
here then he said to them these are my
words that I spoke to you while I was
still with you that everything written
about me this is what Jesus saying
everything written about me in the law
of Moses in the
prophets and in the Psalms must be
fulfilled then he opened their minds to
understand the
scriptures and said to them
thus it is
written that the Christ the Messiah
should
suffer and on the third day rise from
the dead and that repentance for the
Forgiveness of sins should be proclaimed
in his name to All Nations beginning
from
Jerusalem you are witnesses of these
things so who should I take if I'm being
critically if I'm thinking critically
and being honest who should I take
sister n
should I line up with all go with all
the prophets who over generations and
generations apart from each other some
700 years some a thousand some 500 some
300 years apart all for some reason have
the same Revelation about the Messiah
and then we finally get to Jesus who
says yes this is about me I have
fulfilled this that the Messiah should
suffer should I go with them who all
agree and have the same revelation the
same thread or should I go with the
Quran that comes 600 years after Jesus
and then contradicts what we just read
what all the prophets of the past said
over and over and over again who should
I go
with I would say you should go with
whatever everyone else said the prophet
said and stuff like that
boom and that is why sister you should
leave Islam today and come to the truth
of the Messi
so the problem here is that
um that the the previous the
scriptures even like as you showed with
the with the Quran like it seems like
it's true
so the relationship between those
scriptures um is kind of it's not really
one is saying something the other one is
saying something else so it's like you
can't really
know what's true you can though remember
I told you we we know what's true
remember we we said it together we know
what's true when there is consistency
right when you have all the way from the
beginning in Genesis Moses in the
Torah agreeing with David in the Psalms
agreeing with prophet Isaiah agreeing
with Prophet Daniel agreeing with
Prophet Zechariah
and agreeing finally with Jesus the
gospel we see that there's a Common
Thread a
consistency and the only odd man
out is the Quran that disagrees with
them all why I to True H that is true
right so for me what I'm thinking is um
obviously I do believe in the scriptures
the the previous
scriptures but then it's like as you
said said there's a there's a Quran who
says something else so what I'm trying
to piece together is you know what
happened um what happened in the way you
know like from when Muhammad received
his um his
Revelation I'll tell you what happened
from the angel Gabriel oh I'll tell you
what happened sister you are asking such
you see what happens when you think and
you allow yourself to think and these
conclusions are coming oh my God gosh
chapter 1 ver 6 of Galatians I am
astonished that you are so quickly
deserting him who called you in the
grace of
Christ and turning to a different
gospel not that there is another one but
there are some who trouble you and want
to distort the gospel of Christ now
verse eight watch this but but even if
we this is an apostle speaking says but
even if
we or in angel from
heaven should preach to you a gospel
contrary to the one we we preach to you
let him be a
cursed as we have said before now I say
again if anyone is preaching to you
a gospel contrary than the one you
received let him be ACC
cursed so you see here the Bible has
already warned us that there's people
and there will be people in the future
mohamad's not the only one there's a guy
named Joseph Smith there's Ellen G white
and there's a bunch of false prophets
out there there's people that are coming
with a different message that is
inconsistent with the one that we have
already received from the prophets yeah
so yeah I see how it's a it's a problem
so one thing that I have been thinking
about um one question I even brought
this to um a
she I asked this but
the the answer wasn't
really it wasn't really answered so I I
was wondering if anyone saw you know the
prophet to receive the Revelation
because he was in a cave yeah um alone
it was a you know private uh
interaction so but you know afterwards
he came to his wife and he he told her
about the Revelation but no one you know
saw the
actual interaction exactly no one so
that's one yeah there's there's no
witnesses to uh
Muhammad's in interaction in the cave
there's no Witnesses a matter of fact
here's what's
interesting uh you know how supposedly
it's supposed to be the angel Gabriel
well that Spirit or whatever that entity
was that came to Muhammad in the cave
never in never made himself known as
Gabriel
never never ever but here's what's
interesting again on top of that
whenever we look at so it was war that
had to tell Muhammad it was wara that
told Muhammad oh don't worry that's
that's the angel Gabriel who who
appeared to the
prophets now remember our common thing
how do we know something is true with
consistency if it's consistent with the
prophets whenever we look at whenever
Gabriel appears in the previous
scriptures he always makes himself
known he says Be not Afraid I'm Gabriel
here you have this spirit this entity
who wara says is Gabriel doesn't make
himself known to Muhammad doesn't say I
am Gabriel and doesn't calm Muhammad
down doesn't say fear not don't worry be
not afraid he actually incites
Muhammad's fear it's so bad that
Muhammad comes out of the cave it says
that his like his veins are popping you
can see his veins is beating like you
know when you're you're afraid and your
heart is beating really fast you can
even see like your pulse beating vain
pulsing and it says that he went and I'm
reading it right here sah alkari number
three he went to kadijah and said cover
me cover me he was seeking Refuge with
kadijah and it says they covered him
till until his fear was over and after
that he told her everything that had
happened and said I fear that something
may happen to me this is not biblical
you never see this with with the
prophets and and with the experiences
with Gabriel and the angels of God
never yeah it is uh
definitely a problem yeah I
think um a lot of like
inconsistencies as well and everything
that you prevent
presented but to me the biggest thing is
you know this question that I was just
thinking about
because because it was a private we
don't because they say sometimes that
Muhammad did perform
Miracles um not so but the biggest is
the revelation of the Quran that's the
biggest Miracle yeah but
um I don't know remember when we first
started it's amazing when we first
started you had the mindset of where you
you was not questioning you you were not
going to allow yourself to to go into
these thoughts and to go deeper into
this stuff and but you have now allowed
yourself to do so and you see this
stuff yeah that's only the problem I
have here is you know like like you said
the you know what's in between the the
gospel and the Quran like you know what
happened on the way and you know the
fact that you know that the Prophet
Muhammad
um would have been like deceived I don't
know something like that because the
because of the the fact that the Quran
is is contradicting itself
sometimes um so with that logic does
that mean the gospel is the is the TR
truth yes ma'am that means that the
gospel is the truth and it's not because
the Quran is false it's not that's not
why the gospel is true the gospel is
true because it is consistent and in
line with what God has already revealed
in the past before the gospel came into
fruition right we saw in the Torah we
saw in Isaiah we saw in the Psalms we
saw in Zechariah we saw in
Daniel the gospel already being foretold
before we even get the gospel right so
the gospel is
consistent it's a fulfillment of what
the prophets had already revealed
through the revelation of God that's how
we know the gospel is true so yeah I
think uh most most Muslims you know they
you know they see it but maybe they are
you know they're suppressing it because
because of um they're saying that they
have to have faith in Allah that this is
this is the truth and I think that is
the problem because you know I think
every person every person thinks that
some of the things things
that the prophet did was not uh good of
course so you know and then to hold him
to you know a standard to say he's the
most perfect human that there's there's
like an inner conflict within yourself
that you still have to like suppress in
this live that was
you right in this live that was you
that's true and it's not you anymore for
me when I've never seen that these
these verses or these um these hadiths
before so for me you know I've always
heard you the the the Bible is corrupted
the scriptures are corrupted it can't be
trusted but I don't know where where it
came from that I don't know where that
came from I haven't seen the verses in
the in the Quran
so it's kind of like you're in like a
State of Shock you know yeah of course
of course you know when when you're on
the from the outside looking in and
you're looking at the you know the
prophet Muhammad or if you're looking at
the you know Jesus you know I think
there's there's definitely a difference
like when you think about the characters
like Jesus never
married you know like a
nine-year-old so there's definitely a
differences so I you know what I think I
think that now we're at a part where I
can I can Reas you this question
and I think that you're now at at a
place where you can answer it
now what do you think is the better
example following someone who was sinful
or following someone who never sinned
which one is the better
example yeah following someone who's not
the sin who hasn't committed sin exactly
the law of God when it comes down to
sin has a price and the price of it is
death the the Bible says that the wages
of sin the price of sin is death so why
is death necessary because death is the
price by which we had to pay we were
going to have to die and it's not just
like our physical death because we still
die physically right but it's an eternal
death because we sin against God the
punishment is eternal it's Everlasting
and so we needed an everlasting payment
for that to overcome the debt that we
owe now in Leviticus it says this for
the life of the flesh is in the blood
and I have given it for you on the altar
to make atonement for your
souls for it is the blood that makes
atonement by the life the Messiah would
be the ultimate
sacrifice that his sacrifice will be the
Everlasting sacrif sacrifice that
finalizes it
all that's why Jesus said on the cross
he said it is
finished yeah I I can't obviously deny
that that is you know honorable and that
is like a sign of Love obviously like if
the if a mother she would be willing to
die for her child you know and it's you
know it's driven by you know it's an act
of Love basic so absolutely yeah I was
thinking you know how can how can this
be be real because how can God do that
yeah but then but then it's like it has
a problem with you know in the Quran you
know where God is you know he he's all
powerful so it's like why couldn't he do
that it's kind of like
exactly we to decide the thing is um the
thing is you know doubts they are they
are there they are obviously there but
the thing that was suppressing you know
you know everything is questioning is
you know this this faith or this Blind
Faith that you said that is the that is
basically the obstacle so when that is
you know out of the way everything's
just comes you
know like everything it's like a flood
you know yes there's so many things like
yes there's
no yes yeah
amen okay so like how would one go about
if they would want to like get you know
connect with with God yeah well it's
really simple
sister um I can give you a model but
this is I'll I'll give you what to
do um all you have to do is you get
alone you by yourself or you can do it
here no matter where you are and you
come to God
honestly you come to God honestly you
come to him
boldly and you say God in your words it
has to be from your it has to be your
own words in your own heart God
please forgive me of my
sins I believe in you as your lord as
the Lord I believe in your son Jesus
Christ who died for my sins I believe
you Rose him again for the third day you
confess that he died and he rose
again right and you say that you confess
this with your mouth you believe this in
your heart and you confess this out loud
and say I am yours tell him that you're
that you belong to him and tell him that
you are inviting him into your life you
do that you make that confession with
your heart it's true and genuine your
own words instantly you are connected
with God and the Bible says you're
saved and
then after that you then begin your walk
in Christ you get a Bible you begin to
read the gospel read about Jesus and his
teachings read about the prophets um and
also find a church get connected with a
church a good Bible believing church
that's teaching good Doctrine right um
get a community and get connected with
your
church and um and God will lead you from
there okay so first thing it's an
outward confession this is what the
Bible says
here
because
if you confess with your mouth that
Jesus is
Lord and believe in your heart that God
raised him from the dead you will be
saved for with the heart One
Believes and is
Justified and with the mouth one
confesses and is
saved okay for the scripture says says
everyone who believes in him will not be
put to
shame okay so it's an honest heartfelt
confession from yourself from your own
Spirit from your own
heart and you give this outward
confession from the heart that you
believe in God that you believe that
Jesus is Lord and that he God raised him
from the
dead and you you are now adopted into
the family of God you're now a sister in
the
faith do you believe him sister that's
well I ask you do you believe
him believe what do you mean do you
believe do you believe that Jesus is
Lord yeah I have to
say considering
everything um and the evidence and
because I believe in the in the in the
scriptures that the previous ones then
have to they have to say yes
yes and do you believe that God raised
him from the dead for our sins as the
scriptures have
said yeah yes I
do then you're safe
sister welcome to the family of
Christ yeah thank you thank you oh my
logic